>>> THE HOUSE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE HAS RELEASED ITS FINAL
REPORT PLACING THE BLAME
SQUARELY ON SHOULDER OF DONALD
TRUMP.
CALLING HIM THE ONE MAN THAT
CAUSED THE RIOTS AND RECOMMENDS
BARRING HIM FROM HOLDING OFFICE
AGAIN.
IT IS HUGE.
IT IS 845 PAGES AND SUMMARIZES A
YEAR AND A HALF LONG
INVESTIGATION BY THE COMMITTEE
WHICH CONDUCTED OVER A THOUSAND
INTERVIEWS.
IN A NEWLY RELEASED TRANSCRIPT,
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SAID SHE FELT
PRESSURE NOT TO TALK AND INSTEAD
FACE CONTEMPT CHARGES.
SHE TESTIFIED BEFORE THE HEARING
SHE TOLD HER MOM I AM COMPLETELY
INDEBTED TO THESE PEOPLE, THEY
WILL RUIN MY LIFE IF I DON'T DO
ANYTHING THEY DON'T WANT ME TO
DO.
SHE ALSO TESTIFIED, WHEN SHE HAD
A TRUMP ALIGNED LAWYER BESIDE
HER, SHE SAID THIS, I QUOTE, IT
WASN'T JUST THAT I HAD STEPHAN
SITTING NEXT TO ME IT WAS LIKE I
FELT I HAD TRUMP LOOKING OVER MY
SHOULDER BECAUSE I KNEW IN SOME
FASHION IT WOULD GET BACK TO HIM
IF I SAID ANYTHING THAT HE WOULD
FIND DISLOYAL AND THE PROSPECT
OF THAT SCARED ME.
I HAD SEEN THIS WORLD RUIN
PEOPLE'S LIVES OR TRY TO RUIN
THEIR CAREERS, I'VE SEEN HOW
VICIOUS THEY CAN BE.
>> PASSANTINO SAID IN A
STATEMENT HE BELIEVED CASSIDY
WAS BEING TRUTHFUL IN THE
HEARINGS HE REPRESENTED HER FOR.
SO JOINING US POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT AT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" MAGGIE HABERMAN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WE'RE GOING TO GET -- GOOD
MORNING TO YOU BY THE WAY -- TO
THE FULL REPORT.
WHAT WE LEARNED ABOUT CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON WHERE SHE LEARNED
ABOUT HER ESTRANGED RELATIONSHIP
WITH HER FATHER, SHE WENT TO HIM
FOR HELP.
I JUST WANT TO READ SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT SHE SAID BECAUSE I
THINK IT JUST SHOWS YOU, SHE
SAID HER DAD WAS A TRUMP
SUPPORTER AND THEY HAD AN
ESTRANGED RELATIONSHIP.
SHE SAID, LET'S SEE, MY
BIOLOGICAL FATHER, BUT I WENT
TO, I DIDN'T HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH MY BIOLOGICAL FATHER BUT I
WENT OVER TO HIS PLACE ONE
NIGHT, I DROVE TO NEW JERSEY AND
WENT TO HIS HOUSE ONE NIGHT AND
BEGGED HIM, PROBABLY ONE THING I
REGRET IN THIS, I WISH I DIDN'T
STOOP TO THAT LEVEL BECAUSE IT
WAS A NO.
I BEGGED HIM TO HELP ME.
I SAID I WOULD PAY HIM BACK,
NAME YOUR INTEREST RATE, I JUST
NEED HELP.
AND I REMEMBER SAYING TO HIM,
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO TO ME.
>> TERRIFYING.
>> SHE SOUNDS INCREDIBLY SCARED
IN THIS TRANSCRIPT.
AND CHESHE LAYS OUT A CULTURE O
TRUMP LAND WE HEARD MANY OTHER
AIDES TALK ABOUT OVER THE YEARS,
AND SHE WAS CLEARLY WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO HER.
NOT JUST IN TERMS OF TRUMP LAND
BUT SHE HAD NO MONEY.
SHE HAD NO LAWYER, SHE HAD NO
ANYTHING.
AND MARK MEADOWS WAS NOT
RESPONDING TO HER.
MARK MEADOWS WHO HAD BEEN HER
BOSS FOR TWO YEARS.
SO YOU CAN SEE HOW SHE ENDED UP
WITH STEPHAN PASSANTINO.
YOU JUST PLAYED THE STATEMENT
FROM STEFANS PASSANTINO, SHE
ALLEGED HE WAS NOT JUST
REPRESENTING HER BUT TRYING TO
SHAPE HER TESTIMONY.
AND THAT IS VERY SERIOUS AND
VERY SPECIFIC AND SOMETHING THE
COMMITTEE HAS SAID THE DOJ IS
LOOKING AT IT, I SUSPECT WE'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS IN THE
COMING MONTHS.
>> CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE WITH
THE 845 PAGES I KNOW YOU WENT
THROUGH THEM BECAUSE YOU HAD A
REPORT OUT AT 2:00 IN THE
MORNING SO I KNOW YOU HAVEN'T
SLEPT.
WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU?
YOU'VE BEEN REPORTING ON TRUMP
WORLD FOR SO LONG, WHAT STOOD
OUT IN THIS REPORT?
WERE THERE THINGS WE HAVEN'T
SEEN DURING THE COMMITTEE?
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF NEW MEAT
ON THE BONE.
THE STORY IS THE SAME, THE
COMMITTEE FINDS HIM UNFIT TO
SERVE.
SHOWS THAT HE WAS NOT -- YOU
KNOW, THEY STRESSED THIS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, HE WAS AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THIS, HE WASN'T
SOME PERSON BESET BY BAD ADVICE
WHICH IS SOMETHING HIS ALLIES
HAVE TRIED SUGGESTING BUT HE WAS
THE CENTER OF THE WHEEL ON ALL
OF THIS.
SO THAT'S THE MAIN TAKEAWAY.
THERE'S NEW INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW FRUSTRATED THE NATIONAL
GUARD WAS WAITING TO BE
DEPLOYED.
IT WAS STRIKING TO READ.
THERE WAS NEW DETAILS ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY AT WHICH MOMENTS
DURING THE 187 MINUTES TRUMP
KNEW CERTAIN THINGS SO WHEN
EXACTLY HE REALIZED A RIOT WAS
IN PLACE, SOON AFTER THE
CAPITAL.
LATE IN THE 2:00 HOUR, THERE'S A
NOTE PUT ON HIS DESK SAYING
ASHLI BABBITT HAS BEEN SHOT.
SO IT'S NOT AS IF HE WAS A
PASSIVE OBSERVER AND NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT HIS AIDES OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER, THESE ARE HIS
ADVISERS PAINTING THIS PICTURE
OF HIM NOT CARING, HIM IGNORING
THINGS.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT DETAIL I
THOUGHT WAS HIM ACKNOWLEDGING TO
AIDES THAT SIDNEY POWELL WAS
SAYING ABOUT VOTING MACHINES
SOUNDED CRAZY.
THAT FED INTO THE POINT THAT
SEVERAL PEOPLE TESTIFIED TO, HE
KNEW SOME OF THIS WAS NOT
TRUE --
>> HE LOST.
>> CORRECT.
AND YET HE CONTINUED PUSHING
THIS.
>> THAT OBVIOUSLY SHOCKING.
BUT MORE SHOCKING THE FAKE
ELECTORS PLOT.
>> UM-HUM.
>> IF THERE'S ANY LIABILITY
PERHAPS CRIMINALLY, LEGALLY, IT
WOULD BE FOR THE FAKE ELECTORS
PLOT.
>> THAT'S ONE ELEMENT.
WE KNOW THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDED OTHER CHARGES,
INSURRECTION, A COUPLE OTHERS.
I THINK ON THE FAKE ELECTORS
PLOT IT'S NOT JUST DONALD TRUMP
WITH POTENTIAL EXPOSURE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH EXPOSURE
BECAUSE IT'S CLEAR THEY KNEW
THEY WERE DOING SOMETHING THAT
WAS LEGALLY QUESTIONABLE.
I THINK THEY WILL ARGUE, NO WE
THOUGHT IT WAS REAL BUT YOU CAN
SEE IN THEIR COMMUNICATIONS THAT
THERE ARE THINGS THEY WERE DOING
THAT THEY KNEW WERE PROBLEMATIC
AND THIS PLAN BEGAN REALLY
EARLY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THE
REPORT DOCUMENTS.
THIS DIDN'T SPRING UP IN MID
DECEMBER.
THIS WAS GOING ON FOR WEEKS.
THE REPORT CITES REPORTING I DID
SHORTLY AFTER THE ELECTION,
WHERE TRUMP WAS ASKING ADVISERS,
I THINK IT WAS NOVEMBER 11th OR
12th ABOUT HOW TO GET STATES TO
CHOOSE ELECTORS LOYAL TO HIM.
THIS STARTED EARLY.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT SOME
OF THE RECOMMENDATION, AND ALSO
TALKS ABOUT OTHERS SURROUNDING
DONALD TRUMP, PEOPLE THAT DID
NOT COME IN WHEN THEY WERE
SUBPOENAED.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANY TEETH
THAT THIS WILL PROVIDE TEETH TO
ANOTHER AGENCY, OBVIOUSLY THE
DOJ GOING FORWARD TO GO AFTER
ANYONE ELSE?
>> WE KNOW THE DOJ WANTED THESE
TRANSCRIPTS AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THEM FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THEM ALL
NOW, I THINK THEY LOOKED AT A
BUNCH OF THEM ALREADY BECAUSE I
KNOW FOLKS HAVE BEEN GOING OVER
TO DOJ TO REVIEW OR AT LEAST
BEEN GOING OVER THE HOUSE TO
REVIEW.
EXCUSE ME.
SO IT DOES GIVE THEM MORE
EVIDENCE, ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE
WHO WOULDN'T COOPERATE WITH
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
BUT HOW FLUNG THIS IS GOING TO
GO, I DON'T THINK WE KNOW.
I WANT TO MAKE ONE POINT THAT I
THINK IS OVERLOOKED.
THIS IS NOT RELATED TO THE
REPORT OTHER THAN IT'S ADJACENT
TO IT.
THERE'S A LOT OF FOCUS WILL
DONALD TRUMP GET INDICTED?
EVEN IF HE DOESN'T GET INDICTED,
HE IS FACING THIS HUGE FLURRY OF
LITIGATION THIS YEAR.
HE IS FACING TRIALS IN A NUMBER
OF CASES.
HE IS FACING A TOUGH LEGAL YEAR
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS HERE.
>> GEORGIA, NEW YORK, THE STATES
AND THE FEDERAL --
>> A FRAUD LAWSUIT RELATED TO
ACN, TWO SUITS RELATED TO JEAN
CAROL.
>> WHAT ABOUT PASSANTINO, IF
WHAT'S ALLEGED IN THIS REPORT
FROM CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, HE
COULD BE DISBARRED IF FOR THAT.
>> AT LEAST.
HE'S FACING SEVERE LEGAL
JEOPARDY, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THIS.
WE'LL SEE WHAT THE DOJ DOES.
IT IS ON THE DOJ'S RADAR.
I THINK THEY ARE TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY, I DON'T KNOW HOW
AGGRESSIVELY THEY'RE TAKING A
IT, BUT THESE ARE SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS AND HE HAS A
PROBLEM.
>> IT TAKES A LOT TO BE DI
DISBARRED.
IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN.
>> WE SAW IT WITH GIULIANI, TOO.
BUT THIS IS A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
ALLEGATION.
>> THANK YOU, MAGGIE, MERRY
CHRISTMAS TO YOU.